I remember one one occasion we dropped
off
five million in the boot of a car to
some Colombians who on a Friday
and they came back and uh on the Monday
morning you know they dropped us some
other stuff off in another car we come
back Monday morning and I said where the
money was
and they've been driving about Amsterdam
all day well all weekend with five
billion pounding cash in the boot I
didn't even know it was there
[Music]
I came from a really poured out here in
Manchester
there's no nine children nine brothers
and sisters
started crying really early at the age
of eight
shoplifting because we had no choice for
earlier we were shoplifted I didn't eat
carried on and expanded into all little
bits of rubbish
Burgers robbing the school that I was at
uh evolved into cows ringing cows and
fingers and I started sending the cows
to Spain and swapping them
for money at first and then they started
swapping them for cannabis I love music
age of 14 started to merge into that
side of things I put on illegal parties
which were pay parties effectively where
we'd um get an older you know house
clean it up make a makeshift bar in
there and charge people three pounds of
vision to get in
um then I found myself in trouble with
the law when I was about 18 years old
tasted my first little bit of porridge
uh came out and in 1988 there was a new
scene coming out which was warehouse
parties music and we started to put on
huge pies
um all across London and Essex wasn't
long then before
I saw the money that was being made
through the parties with ecstasy and it
just made sense at some point I would
get involved in that particular you know
product
so I got heavily involved in that the
manufacturer and the importation of
ecstasy tablets remember actually first
drug deal I actually done was funny
because it was a painter that used to
work for my mum and dad you know fixing
up some of the properties they had and
he'd uh brought in a few pounds of
marijuana in one of the Kamikaze Mission
from Jamaica after a holiday and he
wanted to uh basically sell it and I was
actually put the deal together but
rather taking some money out of it I
took you know a portion of the wheat and
then gave it to some guys who when we're
going down to the shop but he got the
little button bags where they used to
put the buttons in the little thing bags
that you know button bagging it all up
into what I think five pound or four
pound drawers and giving them a sell it
and that is when I started to get
involved for a taste for drug dealing
once you get to uh a certain level in
cannabis
the the especially when you're living in
most of mine was from Holland I was in
Holland from the early 80s uh lived
there most of the time really and it's a
more uh open thing there nobody's
bothered about cocaine uh heroin was a
bit of an Arty thing even back then but
Cole came was a natural progression from
Cannabis into the clubs
so and it was mostly just sniffing there
was no uh anything after
you know the crack canola there's just
our sniffers that I knew and I knew I
think it's just a natural progression
you know once you get to a certain level
of money with cannabis it's a lot bulky
you don't get as much profit
you know you need to fill a container to
get decent money whereas you get a
suitcase full of cocaine and it's a
massive difference yeah I think um
progression at class A drugs
came in a direction for me because I've
been a warehouse parties I took ecstasy
tablets but before that where I was
coming from you know the thought of
someone taking a tablet or sticking
something a couple of nose it was it was
really schooled on you know and
um I suppose it was different you know a
different group of people I started to
mix with the parties I saw the Ecstasy
is very harmless and United people so I
didn't see any problem with it because I
took on myself I thought you know
there's no problem in being involved in
the manufacturer distribution of them
cocaine was a different story uh cocaine
came obviously after the
um you know the lifestyle obviously yeah
to use it but the ironic thing was
um
the cocaine in levels of smuggling I
could actually probably in terms of
profit margin you know smuggling
marijuana because I smiled it from
Jamaica of producing country
the margins were very similar so even as
she was paying like 50 pounds a pound
for you know high grade marijuana by the
time you'd say loaded that up paid for
your transport cost it was landed there
about a hundred pound 120 pounds a pound
which again could wholesale for two
grand a pound so that's a huge profit
margin with the cocaine it became a
different thing because it was a
question of huge amounts of money and
quicker because you know we could
by cocaine relatively cheap you know and
I mean relative issue about him going
through Colombian places like that where
you could buy paste you know thousand
dollars a key I didn't have it you know
fifteen hundred pound and you could get
it very very cheap and have great
markups with Panama places like that we
just landed down to Guyana she was like
you know two thousand pound a kilo down
now that was loaded you know put a
container and then you know wholesold
here at 25 Granite key so you know the
markups were big
Market at the Moon didn't you the speed
of selling it you know just we could
sell you know cocaine I mean like I
remember getting a container dropped
here at once for 300 key on it and you
know it was sold in 24 hours you know
it's insane this hundred hundred hundred
given this people we couldn't the money
carrying was the biggest problem yeah
and when you used to go and get yourself
tens of millions of pounds
in Canon it took blood evil literally a
month to count the money and actually
multiple candy machines at your highest
point how much would you turn around in
a day
um
well how much a day that's hard to say
yeah it's hard to say some days for me
was Millions
in cash you know
I remember one one occasion we dropped
off
five million in the boot of a car to
some Colombians who on a Friday
and they came back and uh
on the Monday morning you know they
dropped us some other stuff off in
another car we come back Monday morning
and I said where the money was and
they've been driving about Amsterdam all
day well all weekend with five billion
pound in cash in the boot I didn't even
know it was there how does it feel to be
around that much money and that managed
drugs scary sometimes because because
like like we're saying you know it's our
responsibility as well and especially in
my case you know whether it's a
Colombian job who I owe them money to
you know and you can't mess about with
people like that they've got their own
people I I used to have a daily uh house
where I could drop it off to but there's
about three or four Colombians stood
there with machine guns and Hand
Grenades and everything just waiting for
the money coming in and you could walk
in a room and throw a Bim bag full of
money into into the room and there was
plenty of bed bugs already in there yeah
you know so
it just it just become a problem the
money became the same problem as a
cocaine itself it became a product it
was no longer uh money is just big
sacked full of
something inside it I didn't even start
looking you know we had other people to
count it and it was just being delivered
my mindset wasn't really
focused on how much money have I got and
where is it you know and I didn't no
nobody started to do that you know you
shouldn't be in the game yeah because
you transfer it in from you know a
managerial thing and you should transfer
it just like a businessman in my opinion
logistically if you are bringing stuff
in whether it's buttons whether it's
shirts whether it's bloody cars same
thing same thing with your products at
least you know you turn over just spills
back into that you know the more stock
you keep the more money you've got when
you're ready to cash it up you're good
to go
I did it myself we've got a team of us
ago decided to do it so we had eight
people
uh all smuggling 25 kilo that was in the
early 80s or middle 80s we had it
organized locally in Ecuador because it
was a military uh dictatorship really
there at the time and when I took my bag
to the the the conveyor belt there was a
general stood behind a bug and he never
left side of that back and that bag got
put onto the plane at that end it was
safe
but at the time we didn't have control
in the European Airport and we just have
to carry it through
so the only thing that was in my case
was 24 kilo and sponge to protect it
that was it that was the ones that we
did sort of as a Kamikaze really you
know but we got through everybody got
through it was ended up quite good
and then we just evolved into containers
really you just worked with containers
as you know you know we the the people
normally in Colombia that people already
organized a container so you don't have
to deal with that side of it you need to
set up a business obviously to receive
it at this end or wherever it is that
you're coming because I never really
smuggled into it so it's different mine
was all into Europe and it got dispersed
from there into all different places
but the obviously the best way was I'll
be organized on both ends you know make
sure it's a clean through so you've got
bent people on one end and bent people
on the other end dealing with as you you
know yourself hard end yeah but um I
just loved it and that's the worst thing
it was addiction to me because it's
quite a personal I am I like to
experiment things you know
so I said camera cars even the case is
you know we've done those and obviously
Methodist is used was um obviously you
used to have sometimes JP Customs
officers down there don't get me wrong
at the airport who would put them
through the Clear Channel but a lot of
the times we used to um use the hardback
Samsonite cases so there's someone down
at the airport
um and you know in Jamaica or where we
were going from uh put on the case and
the case would literally be Pat jam with
product and in sponge as you said at
both ends so there's no movement you get
22 Key in there because obviously you've
got 25 as the the weight we lift
weighting so you never want to go close
yeah everybody else got 22 I got 24.
over the world record yeah oh yeah
sitting that almost and uh we used to
get to set up tonight suitcase and then
what we did was we'd put a little
scratch right a little big scratch down
one side and then we used to then always
put two cases on the um on the on the
plane so what we'd then do is you'd have
the passenger now you're bored on the
plane it pulled his bit of luggage right
which of course must be product a bit of
a bag right we should go on there and
then we'd have a tag so what we used to
do was tag on one or tag on the other so
we'd have his name on his on his one you
have to scratch on it and then he'd have
his clothes in there but it'll be the
combination lock so you'd have you'd
know the combination to the lock so when
he came at this end he would walk up the
carousel he'd pick up the one with a
scratch on it which is full of gear
right and if he did get stopped and the
Customs will say what's the combination
it given his combination of course that
would be like yeah in opening they'd
live it open Final gear it gets into an
old new cell then of course she'd start
kicking off they say I get this out of
my case and then like about an hour
later when the airport was cleared so
much got it so they'd come back and call
him back in Hay pressed I would give
them the combination they'd pop it he's
got his dirty clothes in now I mean that
he starts kicking off with him it was a
very old one for them to get out of
because of course if he ain't checked in
that luggage it's a question of who
checked it in they know everyone down
there you know got a little team of crap
people you're moving with it and that
was a good one I mean that I'm always
baggage handlers you know used to do
them in transit I mean there's more
methods of smuggling you could shake
your sticker I started doing the the the
planes from from Holland and just flying
with the stuff in you know just throwing
out the plane you know learn how to fly
found at an airport that was uh a little
bit
favorable to what was doing it didn't
really bother give them a nice new card
and he was happy he just turned his eye
and then he even started telling us when
the Customs had been out I mean they
wouldn't be there but everybody knew
what I was doing but nobody was
interested it's mad I think we all think
we do it so much
and that's the thing about it there's no
such thing as a new smuggling method no
and people think oh what are they
talking about in Memphis for the police
know about them yeah the reason why they
don't get them is so many of happening
they just can't they're able tools to
get them all
when I went over to Colombia
I had to go into uh blue Choice it was a
the Don of the calicato
and he'd lost 3 000 kilo through Curtis
and the people in in Holland and
thing again he had no knowledge of it
and unknown to me I walked into the into
the boardroom
and there was about 10 Colombians uh
Lucho was sat in the middle
and the first thing he asked me was
where's my cocaine where's my 3 000 kilo
of cocaine that I had nothing to do with
but I'd come over representing people
who would who'd lost it who'd lost you
know the police had got it and
everything and nobody told them so then
once I'd uh I had to sort of establish
that I wasn't part of that people coming
in and out and every time that bloke
walks out to to check what what I'd said
you know that was if he came in and
something was wrong that was an
assassination you know I weren't going
out of that room luckily I had the right
answers because it was true what had
happened and there was proof of it in in
the world press and everywhere that they
could check
and luckily that that was a bad
interview for me you know I I did
I did convince him in the end and then
we started working again but if you put
yourself in them positions ridiculous
and you know you're walking the things
sometimes and I remember one particular
spray at the time moving space about two
years in total lost eight people
um one person I was really close to
we've done a lot of business together he
um he went for a meeting with some
people in their constituency down in
Jamaica
um car driving now
um they're all sitting on the sidewalk
he pulled out his gun and say he's got a
license firearm could dead license
firearm he fought over police plain
clothes police they pulled out AK-47s
and obliterated three of them murdered
them on the payment and that day had I
been in Jamaica I would have been on
that payment talking to them as well so
I would have been dead you know and then
during that same period of time
I saw so many things you know people
getting shot in the head because you
know putting boots of cars getting set
alike what scared me the most was I got
used to it
well I got 22 years in the absence
because I escaped uh the the day before
uh I was due for sentence the judge went
Happy on the day but it was in 93 so it
was at the time when uh in 92 I had that
this show happened already got about 11
years but for some reason the new
politicians come in stepped everything
up says that they were becoming
terrified of what was coming the drugs
and everything and the more or less
doubled the sentences that's why I
escaped as well because I you know I
wasn't expecting 22 years and it was
only that was for me the first smuggle
which was uh 6.3 kilo from Curacao and
it was 40 kilo of cannabis that's all it
was I'll say all it was it was still
quite a new thing in 1993
but he gave me 22 years in the absence
uh that's when I escaped and shot up to
Holland
got caught there and got another well I
got seven years first
for the 420 kilo Coke
how did you escape
how did they escape from the transport
so I was in in prison called originally
uh president of Liverpool
uh and in the days when when I did that
it was the prison guards took you to
court so we I escaped just by a car
waiting outside waiting for the the the
Cults to come because it was just a
coach not the the the ice boxes that
they have now yeah it was the coaches
and it was the prison guards who used to
attack us and uh in in those days I was
just classed as a a normal prisoner it
wasn't cat a or anything
and uh
obviously with a group I was involved in
they arranged everything from the
outside
and a driver
stole a car that morning and waited on
the car park waited for the culture to
come out
he pulled out and as he's pulled out
he's pulled out on the roundabout just
outside rizzler outside the prison and a
police van pulled up onto the roundabout
where he'd stopped and I thought well
it's on top you know but it wasn't it
was just it was just unfortunate for uh
that the policeman was there the Colts
then the the driver then set off again
went down the Dual College Way waited
for the Colts to come up and pulled out
again and it was up to me to get off you
know I mean he wasn't he was just
getting out of the car
uh I was attached to a young bloke from
Manchester who knew nothing about it I
think it was crossed over like that
and uh he pulled up the Colt streets to
a halt I jumped up and said nobody move
and nobody moved for a bit
walked to the front of the Colts pull
the emergency exit got off
and dragged I was just dragging him
along really he was a lot clue on a big
lad yeah but I dragged him off the couch
got into the back of the waiting car we
took him to Liverpool
so uh swap cars two free cars before we
moved into Liverpool
and got the Cubs cut offers and that was
it I sat in a
a flat for about three months before I
moved and then got a private plane to
Holland and started again but yeah I had
30 years in prison that was my sentence
I did 16 and a half
uh did nearly eight years at triple K
which was as you know it's yeah horrible
extreme it was the first part was in
Holland because it was captured in
Holland
when you say extreme what do you mean
extreme was uh you you'd only sell all
the time on your own
when you come out of the cell you
there's two guards there in what I'm
talking about which was it called a
place called near Roosevelt in in books
in Holland
you come out they pat you down put you
into a cell next door strip search every
time uh
everything off so you stood naked in
front of them they make you bend over
and then you put clean clothes on that
they'd supplied and then you could
either go to your work thing
which was all everything was done
through a three-door system so you
walked into one door it's blocked off
went into another door that door was
open so it took you half an hour to get
anywhere even to get to the works but he
was never in a group with other
prisoners it was just you and the guards
I mean for two years I spent in new
rosterville because the other person
that I was in there with was in for uh
Mass murdering but some of them were
children so I spent more or less two
years in solitary in there and I ended
up playing badminton with the gas
because there's nobody else apart from
him and they couldn't let us out
uh all your visits are behind triple
bulletproof glass
everybody who comes in has to go through
strip searches
when people want to come and visit you
they have to apply six months in advance
and
uh MI5 gone visit them at the the house
and stuff like that you know so that was
a triple K and I spent eight years under
those conditions even when they brought
us back to Holland
entitled it my life and I can't and my
Christmases and New Years yeah so I was
served 10 Christmases and 10 new years
in prison one way or the other
um that should be used custody on remand
or sentenced
I saw some mad things and I'm gonna
forget it was it was like there was no K
anything can happen you know it's a case
everyone's dangerous everyone's a lifer
and you always expect unexpected because
anything can happen I never forget one
day was on the um once I was still on my
mind
um the house but my life has been in
belmarsh and I see this kid he just got
a 34 record I think it was and we were
City to Association I was sitting with
another guy in my cell he was a he'd
done 22 odd years we were talking the
door was open as all the doors were Land
open because walked down the stairs guys
eating his play on his bed guys come
down with a tuna lid and back then you
know if you had a chin or two and I
didn't you could try if you had to open
it you used to get a nail clipper so he
pulled a nail clipper topped it off and
you'd legit ran the tuna tin but you
come off with a jagged edge yeah
um top he's come down with a jagged edge
top the guy's eating his food and he's
walked in it with a big lead and he's
gone boom with it he's brought it down
with all his thoughts I said go in at
the top of his head coming down freeze
forehead he's gone straight for his
eyeball pop that into come out and come
down and put my music chin and when it's
open you can see the bone at his skull
right and that's right in front of me I
couldn't believe what I was seeing right
he's dropped the tuna lid brought back
up the stairs blood's back in it
absolutely everywhere the guards are
locked it down shut it down and I
thought that was like an experience and
I've seen a dozen situations like that
he's getting his hair cut he's going to
shower to go and get himself a shower
upwards guy two of them has come in with
tuna lids and carved into pieces in the
shower you know
um you know hot boiling all getting
thrown over people yeah people who don't
know what we're talking about the oil
was created by they wouldn't let you
have actual cooking oil so they'll let
you have butter which is the Meltdown
into ghee and then they used to put
sugar and jam in it yeah
pour it over people and prisoners think
of some terrible things I mean some of
the tools used to making now I've seen
them get the uh toilet brush
shake that to like the sharpest point
and the way you've got the toilet put a
thing it's not soaked
the turning point for me was uh well 16
and a half years of sat in sometimes
solitary confinement for for years on
end uh just contemplating what I've done
uh the effects of it uh trying to
rationalize it in my own mind of what I
was doing and what I'd done
and what I was going to do when I got
out that was a thing but
I quickly realized that by the time I'd
done me 30 years I was going to come out
as an old man really
uh I think that was one of the the
factors apart from the fact I knew that
I'd done wrong and had
a lot of people had suffered through
what I was doing them type of things are
the ones that hit you more than anything
to make you realize that you miss your
family you've missed your upbringing you
miss your kids coming up you know I
didn't see any of my sons come up
every single then you realize that you
know I'm going to get out of this if I
carry on doing what I'm doing I'm going
back into prison 50 60 years old it's a
death sentence really isn't it it's so
true you know it would be
the changing point of set off developed
a conscience and I've done all these
things in my life out of what I thought
was such a great and exciting life but
what it amounted to is what effectively
brought shame down on my family who are
good hard-working people who wanted to
do better and had better aspirations for
me you know you know thought I was
having this great time but I was driving
around in beautiful cars beautiful
houses flooded over the world first
class living this life for all these
years at the price of others these
people going I'm not having kids food
support and kids tables and you know
broken down relationships and probably
even beating the kids and guys out there
selling drugs in the street against
groom kids to bring them again sell
drugs for them and I was the heart of
this
devilished destructive Circle that I
couldn't even sell as part of that Steve
and then I just it just dawned on me I
got it in prison in my mind I've got a
change but I've got to change it's such
a way that I'm going to be an impact on
the system and like I should smuggle
drugs I'm done ingenious stuff and I've
done all this other stuff just put all
my time and energy into creating a
charity and just putting it all back in
yeah there's uh I don't know any
like drug dealers who have not uh ended
up people doing big sentences or they're
dead
that's the fact
One Bank
who didn't give a toss for their
customers they were told if a Armed
robber comes in don't matter if this
customer's there drop down behind the
counter they can't shoot for a
bulletproof screen what about the
customers customers got to take their
chances